* Das Mädchen
spricht unverständlich. *
* Der Mann lacht. *
- (Mädchen) Grosspapa, schau!
(Junge) Wir zwei hier
und die drei oben?
(Mann) Ich weiss nicht,
ob das klug ist.
Geburtstagsparty
bei Familie Bienz in Kienberg.
Es gibt Grund zum Feiern:
Geburtstagskind Ruedi wird 65.
Rentenalter.
Abschied vom Leben als Unternehmer.
Und Zeit, die Nachfolge zu regeln.
Ich arbeitete lange Zeit so viel,
wie es für mich
kräftemässig möglich war.
Ich kam mit 23 zu Schwabe ...
... und bin jetzt
seit 42 Jahren dabei, mit ...
... mit einem Engagement von 200 %.
Es ist gut, dass
jetzt mal etwas anderes passiert.
So, wer kriegt jetzt Spiegelei?
- (Junge) Ich!
Ach, du, ja - der Chef. Wer
gekocht hat, kriegt zu erst etwas.
Sind ein kaputtes
und ein doppeltes Ganzes okay? - Ja.
Dafür hat Ruedi Bienz gelebt:
Schwabe.
Der älteste Verlag der Welt.
530 Jahre Firmengeschichte,
530 Jahre drucken und verlegen.
Ein Kleinod
mit ewig langer Tradition.
Aber der Druckerbranche geht es mies.
Gutenbergs Handwerk ist nicht mehr
gefragt, das Internet hat übernommen.
Will ein Unternehmen wie Schwabe
unter diesen Bedingungen überleben,
braucht es tiefgreifende
Veränderungen - Ausgang offen.
Deshalb wird diese Geschichte
über einen, der abtritt,
um Neues zu ermöglichen,
auch eine Geschichte
über die Möglichkeit, zu scheitern.
Loslassen ist nicht schwer.
Es macht Freude, den jungen Leuten
diese Dinge weiterzugeben.
Das Schwierige ist jedoch,
die richtigen Dinge weiterzugeben.
Man muss immer wieder entscheiden,
wann man etwas sagen sollte
und wann man besser still ist.
Wann ist es am schwierigsten?
Wenn es um Probleme geht,
die sich nicht
von heute auf morgen lösen lassen.
Wenn man ein gewisses Vertrauen
haben und sagen muss:
"Macht jetzt! Es wird alles gut.",
sich aber nicht ganz sicher ist,
ob man nicht doch noch
etwas dazu hätte sagen müssen,
nicht noch etwas
dazu hätte beitragen können.
Diese Grenze zu ziehen,
ist das Schwierigste.
Hallo, Laurent.
Die Zeit des Patrons ist abgelaufen,
frische Kräfte übernehmen.
Mit den jungen Leuten
kommen die neuen Ideen.
Wir haben diese Veranstaltung
mittels einer Kreativmethode,
sog. Lego Serious Play,
mit dreidimensionalen Notizen
mal skizziert.
Dies ist quasi der Einstieg:
Der Ferrarifahrer, unser Kunde, wird
von einem Medienmacher begrüsst.
Es gibt einen Check-in-Punkt,
an dem die Ankunft der Leute
registriert wird.
Man sieht unsere neue Flagge,
den neuen Auftritt,
den wir vorstellen wollen.
Diese Monster hier sind die
Herausforderungen unserer Kunden.
Auf der anderen Seite
ist unser Schaufenster,
in dem wir Produkte
und Dienstleistungen vorstellen.
Da hinten sieht man
noch den Apero zum Abschluss.
Ein halbes Jahr zuvor:
Am Firmensitz in Muttenz
versammelt sich ein Teil
der Belegschaft zum Workshop.
Bei Schwabe wird alles anders, eine
mittlere Revolution bahnt sich an.
Das alte Organigramm hat ausgedient,
die Hierarchien
werden weitgehend aufgelöst.
Einen Chef,
wie Ruedi Bienz einer war,
wird es künftig nicht mehr geben.
Ich glaube, das ist
für uns einfach der richtige Weg.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass es gut wäre, wenn irgendein
fremder Manager hierherkommen
und diese Firma
auf den Kopf stellen würde.
Es sind Leute nötig,
die wissen, was Schwabe ist.
Diese Leute müssen die Geschichte
unserer Firma spüren und kennen
und die Firma in die
richtige Richtung weiterentwickeln.
Seine Firma mag auf
eine lange Tradition zurückblicken,
Bienz aber verhält sich
alles andere als konservativ.
Reform aus dem Innern,
weg mit den Chefs,
die Verantwortung
auf viele Schultern verteilen:
So will sich Schwabe
künftig organisieren.
Ein unkonventioneller Weg.
Die Aktienmehrheit
hält Ruedi Bienz nicht mehr,
die ist an Ludwig T. Heuss
übergegangen.
Auch das
kein besonders naheliegender Schritt:
Heuss ist branchenfremd und hat
bislang keine Managementerfahrung.
(Mann) Welche Eigenschaften müsste
dieses Orientierungssystem haben?
Die neue Crew soll übernehmen,
aber abrupt wird das nicht geschehen.
Ruedi Bienz will den Prozess
noch eine Weile begleiten.
Dass er sich
aus dem Workshop stiehlt,
ist deshalb fast schon sinnbildlich.
(Mann) Aber ich möchte v.a. Raum
für Fragen und Anregungen bieten.
Inzwischen
schwört der neue Mehrheitsaktionär
sein Team auf Veränderung ein.
Wir haben eine schwierige Situation.
Wir befinden uns
in einem Veränderungsprozess.
Man muss die Dinge ändern,
damit sie bleiben, wie sie sind.
Ich glaube,
das ist genau das, was wir tun.
Wir müssen Schwabe umbauen,
damit Schwabe Schwabe bleibt.
Daran arbeiten wir zurzeit.
Ruedi Bienz ist seit über 20 Jahren
ein ganz enger
und guter Freund von mir.
Ich habe sehr grossen Respekt
vor seiner Lebensleistung,
seinem Werdegang
und vor dem, was er geleistet hat.
Den weissen Arztkittel
trägt Ludwig T. Heuss gern und stolz,
auch wenn er
vor einem grossen Wechsel steht.
Vom Chefarzt zum Verlagschef.
Das löst im Umfeld Reaktionen aus.
Manche fragten mich,
ob ich jetzt völlig spinne.
(Zum Patienten) Ist alles okay?
Aber die meisten finden es spannend.
(Zum Patienten) Es sieht
alles gut aus mit dem Ausgang.
Wir Ärztinnen und Ärzte
haben oft das Gefühl,
wir seien zu bedauern,
weil wir viel arbeiten,
nachts aufstehen
und am Wochenende arbeiten müssen.
Aber das müssen andere auch.
Dies zu erkennen, ist heilsam.
Gut. Haben Sie Schmerzen?
- (Mann) Nein.
Sie haben keine Schmerzen?
- Nein. - Gut.
So sieht Ludwig T. Heuss' Alltag
heute aus:
Er ist Chefarzt
im Spital Zollikerberg.
Endoskopie ist sein Fachgebiet,
darüber hat er
schon seine Habilitation geschrieben.
Der Basler bezeichnet sich selber
als Vollblutmediziner.
Arzt sei der schönste Beruf
der Welt.
Das T. im Namen stammt
übrigens von seinem Grossvater:
Theodor Heuss, dem ersten
Bundespräsidenten Deutschlands
und Begründer der deutschen FDP.
Trotz der Krise
sieht Heuss eine Zukunft
für die Druck- und Verlagsbranche.
Ihre Aufgabe werde in einer Zeit,
in der Fake News hoch im Kurs sind,
sogar zentraler.
Ich glaube, die Aufgabe
eines Verlags und der Umstand,
dass jemand mit seinem Namen und
seiner Verantwortung dahinter steht,
wird letztlich
wieder an Bedeutung gewinnen ...
... weil die Informationslage
immer konfuser wird.
In der Buchhandlung Narrenschiff -
auch sie Teil der Schwabe-Gruppe -
herrscht Ausverkaufsstimmung.
Bücher verkaufen sich
nicht mehr so leicht.
hat Ruedi Bienz
die Zeichen der Zeit zu spät erkannt?
Vielleicht hätten wir zwei
Jahre früher damit beginnen können.
Wir machten vielleicht auch Fehler,
die wir heute nicht mehr machen,
weil wir mehr wissen.
Ich behaupte nicht,
dass wir zu spät sind.
Wir stehen
am Anfang der Digitalisierung.
Es wird noch sehr viel geschehen.
Man verpasst nicht einfach
plötzlich den Anschluss.
Man muss einfach am Ball bleiben.
Ruedi Bienz ist ein Optimist
und sieht eher Chancen denn Risiken.
Die Buchhandlung
musste zwar schliessen,
aber die Räumlichkeiten
bieten nun Platz
für die jüngste Errungenschaft der
Schwabe-Gruppe: den NZZ-Libro-Verlag.
Er sass zehn Jahre lang
neben mir im Büro.
Mit den neuen Kollegen aus Zürich
werden die künftigen Arbeitsplätze
verteilt.
Eine wesentlich erfreulichere Aufgabe
als die Entlassungen,
die Bienz
vor Kurzem ausgesprochen hat.
Acht Leuten, vornehmlich
aus der Druckerei, wurde gekündigt.
Ich glaube, hier benötigen wir
einfach sieben Plätze.
Genau.
- Das schaffen wir schon.
Aber sonst müssen wir
hier noch ein wenig ...
Diese Leute zu entlassen,
tat sehr weh.
Das beschäftigt mich auch sehr.
Ich sagte lange, es
sei eine unternehmerische Aufgabe,
die Angestellten mit der Entwicklung
der Technik mitzubringen.
Uns ging es eigentlich
lange Zeit sehr gut.
Nun hat sich die Entwicklung
stärker beschleunigt als zuvor.
Vielleicht
haben wir nicht ganz überall
unsere Hausaufgaben richtig
und im richtigen Moment erledigt.
Ich glaube,
unsere Reaktion kam etwas zu spät.
Deswegen heisst es:
"Nun hat Schwabe Leute entlassen."
Wenn wir diesbezüglich etwas
sorgfältiger vorgegangen wären,
hätten wir das
vielleicht umgehen können.
Wir hätten nicht mehr Angestellte,
wenn wir es anders gemacht hätten,
aber wir hätten
nicht jetzt Leute entlassen müssen.
Das beschäftigt mich sehr
und es tut weh.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Wir müssen darauf achten,
dass dadurch
keine schlechte Stimmung entsteht.
Denn das sind Kollegen,
die jetzt nicht mehr hier sind,
und es ist nicht einfach,
damit umzugehen.
Das ist ganz klar.
Aber daran arbeiten wir.
Spürten Sie das schon?
- Ja, das spürt man.
Gibt es Widerstand?
- Das würde ich nicht sagen.
Aber es entsteht eine Belastung,
es drückt auf die Stimmung.
Man ist nicht mehr fröhlich,
sondern nachdenklich.
Das ist das Problem,
nicht der Widerstand.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Zu seinem 65. Geburtstag
erscheint die ganze Familie:
Sechs Enkel,
Tochter Nicole mit ihrem Mann
sowie Sohn Roland
mit Ehefrau Michelle.
Hallo. Hi.
Jetzt kommt noch der Rest.
(Alle) Ma-ma-ma-mutschi!
Der Zusammenhalt ist eng,
das spürt man.
Auch ins Geschäft
sind alle irgendwie eingebunden.
Guten Appetit! Bravo, bravo.
Wir sprechen selten über die Arbeit,
wenn wir zusammen sind.
Obwohl wir ja ...
Roli arbeitet ja
schon seit Ewigkeiten bei uns,
Michelle arbeitet auch bei uns
und Nicole auch.
Aber ich sagte immer: "Zu Hause
sprechen wir nicht über die Arbeit."
Kann man das trennen?
- Das klappt gut.
Also, ich kann das gut.
Ich brauche das auch.
Wie?
(Frau) Er wird ärgerlich, wenn wir
zu Hause über die Arbeit sprechen.
Wenn sie lästern, sage ich:
"Jetzt gehe ich."
War es nie Ihr Anliegen,
dass das Geschäft in der Familie
weitergeführt wird?
Roli stellte das
eigentlich sehr früh klar.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie alt Roli damals war,
ich glaube, noch keine 20,
als er sagte:
"Ich habe keinen Bock mehr.
Du erwartest so viel von mir."
"Ich muss."
Ich sagte immer:
"Nein, ich erwarte nichts von dir.
"Ich erwarte nur, dass du
ein anständiger Mensch wirst."
Bravo! Ha, ha.
Der Grossvater hat gewonnen.
Als es vor Jahren
um die Nachfolge ging,
merkte ich,
dass mir Verantwortung
in dieser schwierigen Branche
und in der damaligen Phase
zu viel war
und dass ich das nicht wollte.
Ich habe ja auch noch Familie.
Diese ist mir einfach wichtiger.
Dass ich trotzdem mitwirken
und diese spannende Zeit miterleben
darf, finde ich ganz toll.
Ich freue mich auf das, was kommt.
Wenn er ganz alleine über die
Zukunft Schwabes entscheiden müsste,
könnte ich nicht loslassen.
Ich müsste ja dafür sorgen,
dass es meinem Sohn gut geht
und dass es bei ihm gut läuft.
Jetzt ist er
Teil eines grossen Teams.
Das ist super.
Das ist ...
Das hilft mir dabei, loszulassen.
Bei einem Nachbarn
war so ein Kätzchen ...
Ruedi ist halt überall präsent
und immer wieder ein Thema.
In der Vergangenheit war er halt
wirklich die Anlaufstelle für alles.
Ich denke, es wird sich
sicher seltsam anfühlen,
aber es wird
auch ohne ihn weitergehen.
Ich habe eigentlich gar keine Angst.
Ruedi Bienz hat sein ganzes Leben
in Kienberg verbracht.
Eine kleine Gemeinde
im Kanton Solothurn.
Seine Erinnerungen reichen
weit zurück in die Kindheit,
als die Mutter
vorübergehend krank war
und er sich
für sie verantwortlich fühlte.
Das war das einzige Mal,
dass ich meine Eltern richtig anlog.
In der fünften Klasse
trug mir der Lehrer auf,
meinen Eltern auszurichten,
dass ich ins Gymnasium gehen solle.
Ich war ein guter Schüler.
Der Lehrer wollte wissen,
ob sie einverstanden seien.
Ich erzählte das
meinen Eltern und sagte ihnen,
das sei die richtige Entscheidung.
Doch ich hatte ein schlechtes
Gewissen, von zu Hause wegzugehen.
Mein Vater war ein guter Mensch.
Er arbeitete
sein ganzes Leben lang sehr viel
und irgendjemand
musste sich um meine Mutter kümmern.
Daher sagte ich meinem Lehrer, meine
Eltern seien nicht einverstanden.
Meinen Eltern sagte ich, wir
hätten den Anmeldeschluss verpasst
und ich könne nicht ins Gymnasium.
Damals war es so,
dass Eltern, die aus so einer
tiefen sozialen Schicht stammten,
nicht mit dem Lehrer sprachen.
Das war nicht so wie heute.
Es bestand nie die Gefahr,
dass meine Eltern und mein Lehrer
miteinander
darüber hätten sprechen können.
So wurde ich halt Schriftsetzer.
Das war auch gut so.
* Fröhliches Lachen *
* Sanfte Klänge *
Vom Schriftsetzer mitten hinein
in die Welt der Intellektuellen,
als Besitzer eines Verlags,
der vorwiegend wissenschaftliche
Schriften publiziert.
Da wird auch einem Akademiker
auf den Zahn gefühlt.
Ich gratuliere dir
zu deinem Schritt.
Jetzt musst du nur noch
die nötige Zeit dafür finden.
Das ... Ja. Ja.
Ich habe gute Mitarbeiter.
D.h., dann hast du
auch gute Führungs...
Ja.
- ...erfahrung.
Wenn du die Mitarbeiter
nicht führst ...
Ich hoffe,
Führungserfahrung ich mittlerweile.
Woher kommt das?
- Im Spital muss ich auch führen.
Aber das ist total anders.
Ja,
in einer gewissen Hinsicht schon.
Ich war lange Zeit
Präsident des Verbandes
der Assistenz- und Oberärzte.
Also, ich weiss es nicht,
aber wir werden sehen.
Heuss tritt heute zum ersten Mal
in seiner neuen Rolle
vor grossem Publikum auf.
Sehr geehrte ...
... liebe ...
... Leserinnen und Leser,
sehr geehrte Autorinnen
und Autoren ...
(Baseldeutsch) Und auch
all diejenigen, die denken,
bei Schwabe gebe es
jetzt langsam nur noch Schwaben ...
... möchte ich auch auf Baseldeutsch
ganz herzlich als Gäste begrüssen.
Ludwig Heuss
bleibt seinem Vorgänger treu:
Auch er verströmt Optimismus,
Krise hin oder her.
... weit darüber hinaus
etwas Druckerschwärze
aufs Papier zu bringen.
Wir glauben an das Buch.
Wir glauben daran,
dass man Gedanken festhalten muss.
Ich danke Ihnen,
dass Sie gekommen sind.
Auf die nächsten 530 Jahre
des Schwabe Verlages!
Vielen Dank.
(Mann) Packt an!
Oh, nein!
Nein, nein, nicht heute!
Nicht heute!
Ich darf nicht ins Wasser.
- Doch, doch, du darfst.
* Lachen *
Er fühle sich in beiden Umgebungen
wohl, sagt Ruedi Bienz,
beim Cüpli genauso
wie in der Werkstatt.
Und für Spass
sei er sowieso zu haben.
* Lachen *
Gautschete heisst dieser uralte
Brauch, der hier zelebriert wird.
Zum Abschluss ihrer Ausbildung
werden seit jeher die Buchdruck-
und Schriftsetzerlehrlinge
gewissermassen getauft.
Bis heute, auch wenn sie
inzwischen Drucktechnologe
oder Mediamatikerin heissen.
Allen auf diesen nassen Schwamm,
das dem Sohne Gutenbergs
ist die allerbeste Tauf.
Und rein!
* Lachen *
* Lachen, Applaus *
* Sanfte Klänge *
(Ruedi Bienz)
Jetzt musst du schauen!
Es ist eindrücklich,
wie er dieses riesige Ding auslädt.
Es ist 7 Uhr früh,
mitten in den Sommerferien.
Ja, er macht es sorgfältig.
Man sieht, wie es wackelt.
- (Mann) Ja, ja.
* Lachen *
Grossvater Bienz
hat den Enkeln etwas zu bieten:
Heute wird
die neue Druckmaschine angeliefert.
Ich weiss nicht, was sie tun würden,
wenn er runterfiele.
Mit der Erfindung
des maschinellen Buchdrucks
hat Johannes Gutenberg seinerzeit
eine Revolution ausgelöst.
Mehr als 500 Jahre später
hat die Digitalisierung die Branche
in eine Existenzkrise gestürzt.
Ruedi Bienz glaubt trotzdem an eine
Zukunft auf Papier und investiert.
Knapp 3 Mio. kostet
diese topmoderne Druckmaschine.
Ich glaube, das ist die Mitte.
* Ruedi Bienz lacht. *
Ist es in der Mitte?
- Ja.
Hallo, Dani.
- Hallo, Ruedi.
Du siehst jünger aus als damals,
als du pensioniert wurdest.
Hallo, Jacky.
- Hallo, Ruedi.
Hallo, Heinz. Hallo.
Geht es dir gut?
Nun haben wir uns angetroffen.
- Ja, genau.
Geht es dir auch gut?
- Ja, ja.
Jetzt gehöre ich
dann auch zu den Pensionierten.
Auch das ist eine Tradition:
das sog. Rampenfest.
Zum letzten Mal
mit Ruedi Bienz in der Hauptrolle.
Ich freue mich auf das, was kommt,
obwohl es mir
jetzt etwas besser geht.
Ich muss nicht mehr so viel arbeiten
und kann es etwas ruhiger angehen.
(Mann) Hier ist eine Lücke.
(Ruedi Bienz)
Ja, dort fällt ein Stab.
Dass der Patron am Grill steht,
soll weiterhin gelten.
Auch das wird zu den neuen Aufgaben
des künftigen Verlagschefs gehören.
Wir geben uns Mühe.
- Er bildet mich aus.
Ganz viele fragten,
ob das das letzte Rampenfest sei.
Aber du siehst,
dass die Nachfolge geregelt ist.
(Mann) Das machst du gut.
- Nicht wahr?
Du musst mir das noch beibringen.
Ja, ja. Da kann man
nicht viel falsch machen.